[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and in this video we're
breaking down the brand new images from
it welcome to Derry if you've been
following the channel for a while then
you know the first video that really
blew us up was the one where I pointed
out every time Pennywise was hidden in
the background of a scene that was the
high speed video on the channel and
until squid game came along and I've
been waiting for years now to return
back to Darry to talk about what I think
is the best character in horror I read
the book three times obsessed over all
the intricacies in the movie and I was
so hyped to see that we were getting a
show sent around Derry back when it was
really transformed into a town these new
images look great and throughout this
video we're going to be going through
them all to talk about what they tell us
about the show we're also going to be
going over what we know about the series
as well and there's so much to talk
about now though it's been listed as a
full-on origin story for Pennywise I
don't know if it was sent us early
around just its backstory as we know
this series is going to be set in the
late 1950s slash early 60s anyways
actually crash landed on Earth millions
of years years ago and he landed in what
were going to become North America here
he or rather she sat waiting in
hibernation yeah Pennywise or rather the
creature's real face is female and
they've gone bloody woke now I always
mess up the gender when talking about
her so to keep things simple I'm just
gonna call Pennywise it you don't care
but what you should care about is the
rough timeline of what happened to lead
up to the events of the book which I
want to talk about first now it lay
dormant until people settled in the area
and originally this land was inhabited
by Native Americans using their
techniques they managed to subdue the
creature by carrying out a process known
as a ritual of chud this is something
that the losers Club adopted in Chapter
2 and in the book they defeated it
whereas in the films that they just
shouted things like a live-action
Twitter mob until Pennywise died either
way its greatest plan was that it
allowed the town of Derry to be built up
around it this gave it a steady supply
of food as visitors and settlers would
come by the area and it could constantly
prey on them and children in the book it
says that it is dairy and dairy is it
and in discovering the origins of the
Town we're going to be discovering the
origins of Pennywise anyway in 1715 it
started cycle after Awakening and taking
some children from the settlements
there's a moment in chapter one where
Ben sits in the library and we see him
looking up at a painting where there's a
woman placing a baby in a well this is
actually originally going to be a scene
in the film on which we saw it picking
children off from the town and offering
the mother the option to live or die in
the kids place I jumped to 1740 in which
we get its first real cycle in which it
terrorizes the town for about three
years this was a complete bloodbath and
during it 300 settlers from Derry
disappeared during the first film he
visited Ben's room and sees collected
images from this and can catch Pennywise
standing amongst the saddlers in a
crudely drawn image now then disappeared
for roughly 29 years before emerging in
1769 on this point onwards the creature
continued its cycle and it was
responsible for several atrocities in
the town this included the kitchen
Ironworks explosion which we saw Ben
looking at images of in the library
during part one it also adopted the
moniker of Bob gray which we got to not
to in a chapter 2 when Beverly visited
Mrs Kirsch either way the cycle goes all
the way up to 1957 which I'm guessing is
when the show's gonna take place this
was his estate the merchants and in the
bucket was one of the most brutal
appearances of the clown now
interestingly the timeline in the book
was set during this period and this was
then carried across to the TV adaptation
both of these are the kids growing up in
the 50s so that they could become adults
in 1986 when the other sections were set
however the movie changed things up so
that they could be adults in modern day
and thus the films had the kids growing
up during the 80s both live-action
adaptations have done things differently
to how they lay down the source material
with the 50s and 80s stuff being told
side by side whereas it was laid out
much in the air when they adapted it for
the shows however I think we can kind of
use the basis of the book to guess at
what could happen in the 60s as they
skipped over a lot of the murders to
shorten things down a bit of film in
total there's 17 deaths in just that
part of the book which gives them a hell
of a lot of things that they can now
pull up on now one thing that I don't
think that the movie showed well is how
lucky that the losers club actually was
to survive Pennywise and in the book
they get out most of the encounters by
just the Skin of Their Teeth they have a
chapter where we see things from the
point of view of a kid named Eddie
Cochrane as he runs through the woods
being chased by it just as he makes it
to Freedom he's grabbed and pulled in
and reading stuff like that really
sticks with you I think that the series
could easily have full episodes send
around just one child trying to evade
the monster only to get taken by him
come the end of the entry that takes us
into the images and we have a number of
missing children's posters which was
spotted at the filming locations the
names on these include Daniel van helden
and Peter Boda neither of them were in
the list of pennywise's victims however
we do see some that could hinder what
happens in the show we have a police car
in the streets and later on can see the
office of the chief of police ohnabaki
was called Andrew radermaker that could
be a reason why we get different names
in the show greater marker himself was
killed in a seemingly strange and
violent storm and in order to fill the
position the chief before him would have
had to vacate it I'm guessing that the
series might take a strong focus on the
police due to the missing posters and
the cop car in sign in Derry they were
constantly looking out for why so many
kids had up and banished and chapter two
in the books and is solely around the
death of Adrian melon which is told To
Us by police officer who'd been put on
the case Adrian's death was shown at the
start of the chapter 2 movie but they
skipped over a lot of things that made
the section of the book so creepy
Witnesses saw a clown at the scene of
the crime but fearing that it wouldn't
hold up in court they decided to never
testify about seeing Pennywise there due
to pennywise's Powers it's also able to
psychically put a form of mild hypnosis
over the town in which people on his
interest in the missing kids as they
should be now video posted on Tick Tock
by Mr will Wong took a tour of the sets
and in it he also filmed the outside of
the Derry Police Station so yeah I think
they're giving a lot of focus to that in
the series we know roughly what the
series will be about but I think we
could at least explore this in the
series and it would be great to see
things from the perspective of the
police there's also the fremlin dairy
van and the one for Melvin still looks
like still pickles both of these really
set the time for the series and this
continues when we see the sets
themselves this series is being filmed
in Port Hope Ontario but they've done a
great job of transforming the town we've
got lots of things like the modern
appliance store advertising color TVs
and there's also a sign that says Zenith
this could be another deceiving King
book The planned Zenith Rising though it
could be a reach to be fair on top of
this there's also the Derry press some
Campbell Soup Tins in a window and
another very interesting location we can
see a Chinese restaurant called the Jade
Orion which has links with both the book
and films in then the bank quit scene
happens at the Jade Orion and though the
location is different we could be seeing
the restaurants first or two we have the
dairy Grill the dairy press and also
Second Hand Rose antiques this could go
on to become the antique store where
Bill gets his bike back from and in
Chapter 2 this is where we got the
Stephen King Cameo lastly we have a
really haunting image with a car driving
past a drain and this has one of
pennywise's signatures coming out of it
dangling from the train is a bright red
balloon which the character of course
used to lure kids in with it's a really
haunting image yeah we also got in the
video a picture of signs saying that
this would be the home of the future
Paul Bunyan Monument this was a big part
of the book in second film with a
chasing Richie after Pennywise took its
form the plot synopsis says welcome to
Dairy we'll take a look at a group of
friends who are forced to take on their
credit spheres when children begin to
disappear at the hands of a murderous
clown named Pennywise the series will
portray the events leading up to 2017's
at chapter one and it's gonna be one of
the scariest series out there so though
I did wait on the police I think this is
definitely going to carry the aesthetic
that made the film so popular and the
book in the miniseries of course
influenced shows like stranger things
the series is being overseen by Annie
machete who will direct several of the
episodes however Bill skars God will not
be returning his Pennywise and yeah kind
of bummed out when I heard that however
we know the cast will be made up of
Taylor Page Joe and adepo James Remo and
Chris chalk I think Remar would make a
great policeman investigating stuff and
sorry for constantly hopping on about
that and the series is set to release in
2024 and so far it hasn't been held up
by the writers strike guessing that they
got the scripts at the point that
they're happy to start filming and I
can't wait to see this series next year
anyway let us know your thoughts in the
comment section below and the winners of
our Quantum Mania boxer giveaway are on
screen right now if that's you hit me up
on Twitter at heavy spoilers and
congratulations on winning very proud of
you now if you want to support the
channel for as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below and as a thank you you'll get
access to early videos every week we
also have our merch store over at
xeroedition.com which sells lots of
nerdy inspired t-shirts hats and more
who just launched a peacemaker and Drax
inspired shirt so if you want to head
over there and help us out then the
links in the description now if you want
something else to watch we have a
breakdown of the Game of Thrones
spin-off on screen right now so
definitely head over there right after
this if not then thanks for sticking to
the video really appreciate it I've been
your host Paul and I'll see you next
time take care peace
[Music]
thank you